two five this is good day Las Vegas now  6 24 Welcome Back The Neighborhood  Housing Services of Southern Nevada  hosted its third annual Winter  Wonderland drive-through event on  Saturday Santa and his elves myself  included were there to help distribute  food gift cards even toys and blankets  to more than 1100 people just one  project project Maryland lots of  organizations out there and lots of  volunteers to serve everyone so just a  huge thank you to everyone involved  including that little guy right there  Jeremiah and the Raiders hat he was so  cute everyone working hard and working  with their families to make this year's  holiday a little nicer for all of our  community members love that heartwarming  to see